here's Elsa Nana in 2013's frozen and
here they are in frozen - while they may
look like the characters you know and
love at first glance if you zoom in on
their clothes you'll see how they're
different in the update you can now see
three-dimensional jewels the stitching
and even the finest of threads all these
details wouldn't have been possible in
the first film technological
breakthroughs allowed them to do so much
more for the sequel even creating a
horse completely out of water
[Music]
why did Disney Animation Studios make us
wait six years between frozen and frozen
- well first it wanted to make sure the
original warranted a sequel with a story
worth telling but during that time
Disney Animation which works completely
separately from Pixar made technological
advancements that would let the team
improve on the look and design a team of
about 75 animators worked on the movie
over the course of roughly four years
since one of the major themes in the new
stories change they had a lot of work to
do to update the characters and their
surroundings change mocks us with her
beauty while also remaining true to the
world they created the main character is
Elsa Anna Kristoff and Olaf were created
from scratch for the first film but now
they needed a makeover you can see the
subtle differences in their faces but
even more so in their hair and clothes
Disney Animation had a few movies in
between frozen and frozen - to develop
their animation on his hair was based on
programs used to make the hair in moaña
for Moana they developed a software
called Quicksilver which allowed them to
create realistic hair that could react
to forces like wind water and intense
action according to technical animation
supervisor Christopher ever mallanna's
hair came with a lot of tight coils
while anna had a lot more individual
hairs for them to maintain a new
software called beast allowed them to
simulate more and more hairs per frame
and at a much faster rate
some of the characters will be put
through a rollercoaster test simulation
this identified whether they needed to
add more qualities to the hair such as
thickness hair again was based on
character they made Ana's hairstyle more
mature as the character had aged the
clothing designs in general are much
more intricate than they were in the
original just look at these two shots of
Anna and Elsa in frozen and frozen - you
can tell from this shot in the second
movie where onon elfs are standing in
the Enchanted Forest that their clothes
are much more detailed Elsa's dress no
longer looks like it's covered in just
two-dimensional sequins instead there
are incredibly detailed little jewels
everywhere meanwhile you can now even
see all the little stitching on on
escape and in this shot we're on an Olaf
are enjoying the warmer weather you can
really see every little thread in Ana's
dress while Elsa goes through some
costume changes
animators made sure whatever she was
wearing was part of a cool colour
palette the animation team felt if they
went too warm with the color choices
something would feel off as certain
colors become associated with certain
characters movement was also an
essential trait to get right getting an
animated character to move is all about
mastering control points every finger
has three or four control points alone
in frozen - Elsa's feet had multiple
control points so she would look natural
while moving barefoot which was
important given that her most important
actions happen while barefoot and
movement like clothes and hair can be
used to define character traits the
animators utilize movement to
demonstrate how the characters change
since the first film as well as the
differences between them
Elsa walks and reacts with refined
movement especially compared to Anna who
was much more animated in her actions
and while the two sisters spent most of
frozen a part in frozen - they're
together most of the time so the
differences between them are even
starker you can see this especially in
the charades scene
elsa is mostly silent listening and
moving just straight up and down while
anna's moving around with her whole body
yet elsa who is much more confident now
than she was in the first movie walks
with a much greater sense of purpose
there's a detail even more subtle than
movement that the animators needed to
get right breathing it's especially
essential for a movie involving singing
the animation team even brought in a
vocal coach to teach them about the
kinds of breathing techniques a
professional singer would use take a
look at this scene when Elsa singing
into the unknown we can see all the
subtle movements in her body almost as
if we were watching
idina menzel recording the track but
there are some new characters here that
posed an even bigger challenge for the
animators and that's because they aren't
human or creature but the elements now
on most computer animated movies visual
effects and animation teams work
separately the animators create the
characters and the visual effects team
adds computer simulations like weather
effects or how a piece of clothing will
drape over a character what do you do
when the effects are your characters
there is no better example of this than
Gale who's a gust of wind wind would
usually be a visual effects simulation
added in later on in the process but
here it's a character so they had to
create a new program for the animators
just for this called swoop usually you
just see the end result of wind but this
time we see it as a whole character to
get this basically invisible character
right a wind rig ran alongside given
scenes and they were able to manipulate
its size and add simulations to this
that help determine Gale speed and path
here's Gale blowing into a house and
pushing Sven out the door
creating Gale also required working
closely with the environments team on
elements such as the leaves that gets
swept up by Gale for instance when Olaf
is singing his when I am older solo
piles of leaves needed to be placed on
the ground for Gale to pick up at one
point early in the design process they
contemplated having Gale take the form
of the other characters mimicking their
shapes with debris
and animators had to think about whether
at any given moment Gale was supposed to
be playful or dangerous but let's not
act like this wasn't a fun challenge
along with studying physics the
animators went skydiving for inspiration
the skydiving experience certainly shows
if you look at this shot of Bruni being
swept up by the wind he has his arms and
legs out in skydiving form the elements
came in all shapes and sizes the biggest
ones were the earth giants because of
their large size the earth giants had to
move very slowly to design them the
animators actually incorporated
characteristics of the trolls from the
first film as you can see from these
drawings they shared a lot of the same
features from the shape of their torso
to the size of their nose not
surprisingly making a giant made out of
rocks move isn't easy
the rigging process was intense as the
rocky forms and asymmetrical bodies
restricted their movements it was also
important that each piece of rock moved
correctly and didn't go through another
rock and last but certainly not least
there was the knock the water horse
which was the product of eight months of
hard work there were several challenges
to creating a creature made out of water
that also needed to be true to the look
of an actual horse because it has no
pupils or real eyes for that matter it's
a lot harder to convey the characters
emotions so the animators relied on the
Knox ears they made the ears point to
wherever the knock was looking while
also conveying its mood if the ears
point back the horse is angry if the
ears point to the riders they respect
the rider but before the animators could
control its emotions they had to figure
out how to control the water it's made
of while the water in moaña had some
personality it was nowhere near this
complex in early tests there was way too
much water coming off the mane and tail
which animators described as looking
like a fire hydrant
they eventually controlled it to the
point where it looked more like a gentle
waterfall the nock also had to look like
he was part of the ocean so they looked
at elements of the actual ocean
like mist and spray which forms at the
end of the mane and tail as it moves
staying true to the water form also
required making the noch different from
an actual horse in some ways like the
way it moved when the nock is running on
water you can see the hoof sort of break
and stretch which is apparent if you
slow down this clip of the nock running
on a wave to get a sense of actual
horses animators studied horse anatomy
met with a horse trainer and actually
rode horses it was important not just to
capture the look of horses but the
weight of them so Elsa could really get
a sense of this creatures power while
all the characters went through
transformations a lot changed in their
world as well in frozen much of the land
is covered in snow so the animators went
to Cheyenne Wyoming to walk through
waist-deep snow and see what it would be
like for the characters but in frozen -
it's supposed to be autumn so the snow
is melted this presented new challenges
since more of the ground and
surroundings were revealed there were a
lot more details that needed to be
included in each shot particularly in a
new setting for the movie the Enchanted
Forest every tree rock and plant
required a lot of planning and work to
get where it is for inspiration the team
ventured to the wilderness of Norway
Iceland and Finland to experience what
the characters they were animating would
be experiencing and to get inside their
heads while there they studied the
landscape and the culture and even stood
on a glacier to see what it would be
like for Elsa to stand on one they also
worked with a botanist to determine what
trees and plants would realistically
grow in the area just like Elsa's outfit
a crucial part of establishing this
particular setting was nailing its color
palette which they wanted to be in line
with the first movie as you can see in
this shot of the enchanted forest
the leaves are mostly orange in magenta
there's barely if any yellow which is a
color usually associated with fall
compare that with this opening scene in
frozen and you can see how similar they
really are
many of the shots in this forest were
purposely shot extra wide to make the
characters feel more alone and isolated
while much of the film takes place in
new lands frozen 2 also revisit some
familiar places particularly arendelle
arendelle is covered in snow for most of
the first movies run but remember it's
autumn now so the kingdom needed a
makeover of its own because buildings
were no longer covered in snow animators
had to add lots of new details they
filled in roof details in places where
there might have been snow originally
but there were also some buildings
designed with colors that were
specifically meant to look good with
snow and ice these buildings received a
new paint job so they'd look good
against the brand-new fall backdrop one
of the big turning points in frozen to
happens in the dark sea this is where
the NOx scene takes place animating
realistic water is not easy and
animators use what they've learned on
previous Disney films to make it work
for the dark sea they were largely
inspired by Rana sfera a black sand
beach on the southern coast of Iceland
nailing the scene required a lot of
coordination between the animation team
and the visual effects team and since
she was going to be walking on the
simulation it all had to match up
perfectly the animators also mastered
some factors about water that you never
think of like house an looks when it
gets wet after getting hit by a wave
Disney Animation developed another
simulation engine for Moana called
splash which gave them a lot of practice
making the open seas through this they
could calculate for example what it
would look like for a wave to break for
Moana
the challenge was trying to make the
water calm but for frozen - it was
important to make the waves big and
overpowering while still seeming real
you can see those realistic waves
directly here as Elsa stares them down
on the beach before running in head-on
while these look incredibly realistic
the animators actually pulled back so
they didn't look too real sure they now
had the tools to make it look like
actual water but sometimes it's more
important that your animation looks
realistic for the animated fantasy world
your curry
not necessarily for our world otherwise
you take away from the magic that
started all back in 2013
[Music]